I have to tell you something
Wednesday night on the Real Housewives
of New York Bethenny Frankel decided to
tell LuAnn de Lesseps about her fiance
Tom's alleged cheating I don't want this
to be happening right now
- why are you doing this the decision of
whether to reveal what she'd heard had
been tearing Bethany apart there's
nothing about this that I want to be
doing right now so why go through with
it I spoke with the Skinnygirl mogul at
her home in the Hamptons it's the
age-old question would you want to know
I I would want to know this was the
information I got was the day before
Luann's engagement party had been
engaged for a week had they had three
kids together and been married for 25
years I bet I wouldn't have said
something but I think when you've been
engaged to somebody for a week that
you've known for three months you tell
them you can get out alive you know this
is I think this this is a history that
this person has and there were a lot of
red flags from the other housewives
saying multiple different stories and I
think LuAnn really just wanted to be in
a relationship I think LuAnn wants to be
in love and is in love with being
viewers have to watch the show's season
finale August 24th to find out how LuAnn
reacts to the devastating reveal but the
countess has made it clear on social
media that she and Tom are still
together and engaged today Frankel says
she hasn't seen LuAnn much this summer
she's focusing on her businesses
including the launch of her new
Skinnygirl watermelon lime margarita you
gotta have one more drink with me